[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend wir sind mitten in einem
blindflug bei der korona pandemie bei
den statistiken über die feiertage ist
das deutsche meldesystem so lückenhaft
das robert koch institut davon abrät die
eigenen zahlen dieser tage zu schlüssen
zu benutzen einen hinweis geben die
täglich gezählten todesfälle in
verbindung mit corona montag letzter
woche waren es 119 dienstag
426 mittwoch 510 und heute waren es 69
als ob der tod am zweiten
weihnachtsfeiertag eine pause macht
macht er natürlich nicht deutschland
setzt auch heute und morgen schön jedes
bundesland für sich verschärfte regeln
in kraft im einzelnen finden sie das auf
zdf heute schaut man auf das große bild
auch über deutschland hinaus dann wird
klar dass die befürchtete omikron welle
sich aufbaut wie befürchtet ein
überblick von dalian tag
mehr als 100.000 neuinfektionen in
frankreich binnen 24 stunden mit dem
höchststand schwappt die überlastung in
die kliniken schon wieder
es gibt erschöpfungs wellen wie in der
akademie haben ist sind zu lasch die
korona maßnahmen der regierung vor
weihnachten finden viele auch der unmut
unter den bürgern wächst
alles was die regierung ankündigt reicht
nicht seit zwei jahren geht das so neu
corona maßnahmen dann am frühen abend
fazit einen lock down soll es nicht
geben nicht mal vier monate vor der wahl
will frankreichs regierung seine bürger
nicht verprellen
härter durchgreifen gegen die omikron
welle verspricht new york scheidender
bürgermeister debler sie als erste
us-stadt gilt ab heute die impfpflicht
ausgeweitet auf beschäftigte privater
unternehmen und damit für mehr als
180.000 firmen und deren kunden
mit der impfpflicht macht es die stadt
einem schwer sich zurechtzufinden
du kannst in keinem restaurant essen und
dich hinsetzen und entspannen und
arbeiten kannst du nur wenn du home
office deshalb habe ich es für das beste
gehalten nicht impfen zu lassen
doch ganz so versöhnlich sehen das nicht
alle
die verfassung der vereinigten staaten
wird verletzt
in deutschland wie hier in duisburg
sollen im angebote die letzten
unentschlossenen überzeugen noch immer
sind rund
21,7 millionen ungeimpft rund 26 prozent
ziel der bundesregierung bis ende januar
sollen 80 prozent der bürger innen
mindestens einmal geimpft sein wie viele
sich hier noch umstimmen lassen potsdam
am frühen abend eine mischung aus
unentschlossenen impfgegnern querdenkern
und gegendemonstranten
dresden am abend die stimmung aufgeheizt
helfer
[Musik]
erst sonntag hatten im bayerischen
schweinfurt mehrere hundert menschen
unangemeldet und teils mit gewalt gegen
korona maßnahmen protestiert
polizeibeamte und ein kind wurden
verletzt heute das urteil in einem
schnellverfahren gegen vier
festgenommenen demonstrierende
der attacke leitet bei uns die redaktion
recht und justiz
strafurteile in weniger als 24 stunden
nach der tat sarah wie ungewöhnlich ist
es grundsätzlich ist es möglich solche
schnellverfahren durchzuführen das
passiert auch immer wieder es hat aber
zwei zentrale voraussetzungen einmal der
täter darf nicht zu mehr als einem jahr
verurteilt werden und das zweite ist
ganz zentral es muss ziemlich klar sein
was passiert ist also im zweifel liegt
schon ein geständnis vor oder es ist
relativ eindeutig was da passiert ist
diese zwei wochen aussetzung gibt es
deswegen werden schnellverfahren
beispielsweise oft angewandt nach
fußball spielen wenn es der
gewaltausbrüche gibt somit mit hooligans
dann gibt es solche schnellverfahren
oder aber bei drogendelikten oder auch
bei obdachlosen wenn jemand keinen
festen wohnsitz hat das heißt das
zentrale ist immer im strafprozess geht
es um die wahrheitsfindung und im
strafprozess geht immer gründlichkeit
vor schnelligkeit deswegen
schnellverfahren wirklich nur wenn es
möglich ist weil der sachverhalt relativ
klar ist aber gerade bei diesen
spaziergängen die ja gelegentlich als
provokation gemeint sind oder bei
gewalttätigen demonstrationen unheimlich
viel polizei anwesend ist das sind ja
immer wieder fälle wo die dinge an für
sich völlig klar liegen wird das nicht
häufiger angewandt ist in der tat zum
ersten mal dass diese schnellverfahren
nach so einer corona demonstration
öffentlich werden in dieser form nun ist
es auch dass nicht jedes
schnellverfahren immer öffentlich wird
weil genau da wo die justiz funktioniert
da wird nicht so oft hingeschaut sollen
wir schauen immer eher auf die
missstände das heißt das kann es immer
mal geben aber in der tat es ist zum
ersten das die verfahren in der form
öffentlich werden und es ist auch so
dass die bayerische justiz gerade
bekannt dafür ist dass sie eine schnelle
strafe auf eine tat folgen lassen will
das ist kriminologisch gesehen auch
durchaus sinnvoll weil die strafe wenn
sie schnell auf die tat wird eine
größere abschreckungswirkung hat und es
kommt nun darauf an ob auch andere
staatsanwaltschaften in deutschland
sagen das ist weg den beginn wollen eine
härtere gangart um auch der gewalt die
da der gewaltausbrüche einheit zu bieten
die wir auch gehen wollen denn es liegt
an den staatsanwaltschaften diese
schnellverfahren diese beschleunigten
verfahren zu beantragen
aber das signal dafür steht zur
verfügung ist es eine entscheidung der
staatsanwaltschaft gehen wir diesen weg
haben wir das material dafür oder tun
dies nicht genauso ist es die
rechtlichen möglichkeiten sind da man
muss sie nutzen dankeschön saar attacke
wie spricht man mit erbitterten gegnern
von zum beispiel impfungen und aktueller
kroner politik nasa guckte mir fragt
dass frank richter um etwa 19 den mann
der einst in dresden einen dialog mit
anhängern der pga bewegung in die wege
geleitet hat die aktuelle welle der
comic-con variante gefährdet nicht nur
menschen die krank werden erkrankte und
patienten in quarantäne fehlen auch an
entscheidenden arbeitsplätzen der
medizin und pflege klar aber auch an den
arbeitsplätzen in der industrie und bei
dienstleistern aller branchen für
forschungsinstitute die deutschen
industrieverbände und die bundesanstalt
für arbeit könnte das ein vorgeschmack
sein auf ein problem gegen das keine
impfungen helfen wird nämlich massiver
struktureller fachkräftemangel bald
schon werden hunderttausende fehlen wenn
nicht zuwanderung und fortbildung helfen
martin niesen über ein problem das
schneller wächst als von den meisten
erwartet
überall wird gebaut und saniert und
alles ist komplexer geworden
zur warmwassergewinnung reicht kein
einfacher heizkessel mehr da muss
solartechnik her so wollen es die
klimaschutzgesetze von bund und ländern
die anforderungen an heizungsbauer etwa
steigen stetig wenn sie früher in
hamburg ein kessel getauscht haben dann
haben sie dafür zwei tage gebraucht nach
dem ersten sieben mit dem hamburger
klimaschutzgesetz brauchen sie eine
woche weil sie müssen jetzt auch
solarthermie unter umständen mit aufs
dach bringen gleichzeitig aber fehlen
gerade im handwerk fachkräfte
geburtenstarke jahrgänge gehen in rente
der nachwuchs studiert lieber in hamburg
sind mehr als die hälfte aller
ausbildungsplätze in sogenannten klima
berufen für das kommende jahr unbesetzt
von den 20 engpass berufen der
bundesagentur für arbeit kommen 13 aus
dem handwerk die top drei sind die
bereiche leitungs installation tiefbau
und sanitär heizung klima technik also
zentrale bausteine um überhaupt die
klimawende an die gebäude und in die
gebäude hinein zu bekommen der
fachkräftemangel nimmt dramatische
formen an und nicht nur in der pflege
der hotellerie und gastronomie oder der
logistik
laut hamburger handelskammer fehlen
allein in der hansestadt aktuell 58.000
fachkräfte bis 2035 wird sich diese zahl
auf
127.000 mehr als verdoppeln in vielen
flächenländern sind die zahlen noch
drastischer der mangel betrifft branchen
die in den kommenden jahren und
jahrzehnten immer wichtiger werden nicht
nur für die klima wende in der alternden
deutschen gesellschaft fehlen auch
optiker und akustiker der markt ist
tatsächlich leer gefegt einer augenoptik
und hörakustik und deswegen setzen wir
auf die eigene ausbildung und das werden
wir in der größenordnung wie jetzt auch
die nächsten jahren jeden fall weiter
tun müssen
1500 auszubildende pro jahr wollen aber
auch erst einmal gefunden werden die
konkurrenz der unternehmen auf dem
arbeitsmarkt ist groß im baugewerbe
setzen sie auf social media und eine
gestiegene attraktivität der
handwerksberufe wir müssen auf den
sozialen kanälen jetzt suchen aber wir
sind zuversichtlich dass das klappt es
ist auch so dass durch die
digitalisierung und durch den anteil an
elektronik und solchen geschichten der
beruf interessanter wirkt auf die jungen
leute und schließlich bietet die
heizungsbauer zunft nicht nur
arbeitsplätze mit sicherer
zukunftsperspektive sie tut auch etwas
für das klima
also auch positive nachrichten nun von
grunde lag auf die wirtschaftliche
situation der krankenhäuser in
deutschland ist so schlecht wie seit
über zwanzig jahren nicht mehr nach
angaben des deutschen krankenhaus
instituts rechnen 60 prozent aller
kliniken mit verlusten trotz staatlicher
hilfen gegenüber 2020 werde sich der
anteil der häuser die rote zahlen
schreiben verdoppeln hauptgrund für die
geringere auslastung sei die pandemie
wegen der planbare operationen abgesagt
wurden zugleich warnen auch die kliniken
vor dem fachkräftemangel und dem sich
zuspitzenden personalmangel in der
pflege der vorsitzende des welt ärzte
bundes montgomery steht wegen äußerungen
über urteile zu corona regeln in der
kritik der zeitung die welt hatte er
gesagt er stoßen sich daran dass so
wörtlich kleine richter leihen sich
hinstellten und wie in niedersachsen
zweig im einzelhandel kippten weil sie
es nicht für verhältnismäßig hielten
dagegen verwahrt sich der bund deutscher
verwaltungsrichter und richterinnen auch
bundesjustizminister buschmann wies die
kritik zurück und forderte respekt vor
der unabhängigen richter schafft
polens präsident duda hat sein veto
gegen ein umstrittenes rundfunk gesetz
eingelegt das den einfluss ausländischer
unternehmen auf die medien beschränken
soll nur muss das parlament erneut
beraten duda erklärte grundsätzlich sei
er dafür ausländisches eigentum an
medien zu begrenzen es gehe aber auch um
meinungsfreiheit zudem schade das gesetz
den ruf polens als wirtschaftsstandort
in ganz polen hatten zehntausende gegen
das geplante mediengesetz protestiert
und freie berichterstattung gefordert
nachdem die behörden den vulkanausbruch
auf der kanaren insel la palma für
beendet erklärt haben sind nun die
aufräumarbeiten voll im gange insgesamt
wurden fast 3000 gebäude darunter auch
schulen und gesundheitszentren zerstört
gut drei monate dauerte der ausbruch des
vulkan chromgrill vera über 1200 hektar
der insel sind jetzt mit einer lover
schicht bedeckt die immer noch auskühlt
von allen entscheidungen des mc america
great game präsidenten trump war die
kündigung des atom abkommens mit iran
eine mit dauerhafte wirkung sie kamen
nämlich mit den schärfsten sanktionen zu
denen die finanz großmacht usa fähig ist
sie hat damit überraschend wenig
erreicht die iranische wirtschaft geht
zwar am stock aber auch nicht schlimmer
als vorher und das atomprogramm der
islamischen republik hat sich eher
beschleunigt der neue präsident joe
biden versucht seit amtsantritt die
heranwachsende atommacht iran wieder
einzufangen ohne einen krieg mit
versprechen sanktionen zu lockern wenn
das atomprogramm aufhört das erweist
sich nun aber als äußerst schwierig die
mullahs in teheran haben ja bei trump
gelernt dass der satan usa sie nicht in
die knie zwingen kann unser iran
korrespondent berichtet
die runs revolutionsgarden lassen die
muskeln spielen ein martialisch
inszeniertes propaganda video zeigt
raketentests vor wenigen tagen in der
iranischen küste die botschaft an die
erzfeinde usa und israel wir haben die
waffen um israel direkt zu treffen
israel sollte aufpassen keine fehler zu
machen denn beim kleinsten fehler werden
wir ihnen die hände abschneiden
irans konservative medien feiern die
waffentests als starkes zeichen vor den
atomverhandlungen nach dem motto wir
meinen es ernst für den amerikanischen
nuklearwaffen experten david albright
gilt das auch für toleranz atomprogramm
er ist sich sicher iran ist heute
technisch in der lage sehr schnell die
bombe zu bauen
die frage ist wie viel waffenfähiges
uran kann iran produzieren und wie
schnell ich denke es sind nur noch
wenige wochen es waren mal viele monate
doch der zeitraum ist geschrumpft auf
nur noch wenige wochen
zeit auch iran aus dem atom abkommen
ausgestiegen ist produziertes mit
modernen zentrifugen auf über 20 prozent
angereichertes uran
ein entscheidender schritt auf dem weg
zu einer bombe die lage sei ernst meint
nuklear experte david albright
wir sehen die entwicklung eines
perfekten sturms da sind wenig effektive
oder stockende verhandlungen wir sehen
dass sie iran seine waffensysteme
weiterentwickelt hat und gleichzeitig
haben wir immer weniger einblick in das
was vor ort passiert um die
internationale gemeinschaft warmen zu
können falls iran eskalierende schritte
unternehmen will
irans führung aber will inspektionen der
atomanlagen erst wieder zu lassen wenn
die us-sanktionen komplett wieder
aufgehoben werden
wir müssen wieder unser öl ohne
beschränkungen verkaufen dürfen und das
geld dafür wo es auf den iranischen
bankkonten in fremdwährung ankommen wir
müssen in den genuss aller
wirtschaftlichen zugeständnisse kommen
die im atom abkommen festgelegt wurden
irans regierung aber steht ihrerseits
unter druck die wirtschaftliche lage ist
schlecht das volk ist müde will
fortschritte sehen
diese verhandlungen machen uns krank
seit zehn jahren verhandeln sie wir sind
schon allergisch dagegen
sanktionen treffen in keinem fall die
politiker sie treffen einzig und allein
die einfachen leute
die politiker auf beiden seiten aber
pokern weiter mit drohgebärden und
taktischen spielen denn bei den
gesprächen in wien geht es um viel um
viel geld und vor allem um krieg oder
frieden
in den flutgebieten des letzten sommers
in der eifel und im aartal sind im juli
über 180 menschen gestorben die trauer
darüber und die gewaltigen schäden sind
noch lange nicht überwunden aber mit dem
neuen jahr werden fragen nach fehlern
und nach verantwortung lauter werden das
müssen sie auch dafür ist in der
entscheidenden nacht zu viel
fragwürdiges passiert oder eher nicht
passiert besonders an der awo am
oberlauf des flusses schon gewaltige
schäden entstanden waren und
flussabwärts noch stunden später keine
warnung ankam da war es für viele zu
spät bobby cherry an bericht
hausärztin astrid nickel hatte viel
herzblut in ihre praxis in dernau
investiert 13 jahre lang arbeitete sie
hier bis zum hochwasser im juli seitdem
habe sie einiges verdrängt sagt michael
jetzt in der dunklen jahreszeit werde
ihr und vielen anderen menschen im ort
klar wie groß die verluste durch die
flut wirklich sind ich kenne das so dass
ich hier durchfahren
ich konnte mich
wie konnte es zur zerstörung dieser
idylle kommen warum mussten im aartal
134 menschen im hochwasser sterben
existierten und funktionierten die
notwendigen wahn systeme am 14 juli
passierte die flutwelle gegen 17 uhr den
ort schuld noch neun stunden später um 2
uhr 30 nachts starben menschen in sinzig
seit oktober beschäftigt sich ein
untersuchungsausschuss des rheinland
pfälzischen landtags mit der katastrophe
vergangene woche startete die
beweisaufnahme im ahrtal die frage
stellt sich am ende des tages ob es
politische verantwortung gab es ob es
fehlverhalten gab
menschliches fehlverhalten
organisatorische fehler die dazu geführt
haben dass hier in einer solchen anzahl
menschen ums leben gekommen sind hätte
man das verhindern können erste frau im
landtag rheinland-pfalz sind bisher rund
50 aktenordner beweismaterial
zusammengekommen die regale werden sich
wohl noch fülle zurzeit werden daten zur
bodenbeschaffenheit des anteils
gesammelt und ausgewertet unter dieser
erarbeitung phase steht auch noch am
anfang und wir kommen dann auch in
dieser phase wo dann auch die
warnstufen die es gab zum beispiel
erkenntnisse des deutschen
wetterdienstes dann eine rolle spielen
werden auch die staatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt im fokus der ermittlungen
steht der ehemalige landrat des kreises
ahrweiler jürgen pföhler cdu aber auch
spd innenminister roger lewentz musste
sich viele kritische presse fragen
gefallen lassen die parteien stehen sich
in regierung und opposition gegenüber
deshalb sei der untersuchungsausschuss
wesentlicher bestandteil der
aufarbeitung so experten das ist gerade
in rheinland-pfalz wichtig da regiert
die spd auf landesebene die cdu war im
landkreis dominierend und da kann sich
natürlich ein schweigekartell gründen
dass man dafür untersuchen das gar nicht
groß damit dahin und mein fehlverhalten
nicht rauskommt und das signal das
möchte man senden dass das nicht der
fall ist durch die flutkatastrophe sei
vielen menschen im aartal das gefühl von
geborgenheit und sicherheit
abhandengekommen sagt ärztin astrid
neckel inwieweit die politische und
juristische aufarbeitung daran etwas
ändern kann muss sich noch zeigen
durch diese flut katastrophe entstanden
massive schäden für die auch die
versicherungen aufkamen der
gesamtverband der deutschen
versicherungswirtschaft bilanziert das
teuerste naturgefahren jahr seit beginn
der statistik anfang der 1970 er jahre
sina mainitz welche schadenssummen haben
denn die versicherungen übernommen
tatsächlich so viel wie noch nie mit
12,5 milliarden euro beziffert der
gesamtverband der deutschen
versicherungswirtschaft diese schäden
das vergangene jahr bleibt in erinnerung
weil viele menschen wie wir eben gesehen
haben ihr hab und gut verloren haben im
aartal riss diese verheerende flut im
juli 134 menschen in den tod die schäden
durch die wassermassen sind immer noch
sichtbar nach wie vor müssen menschen in
ausweichquartieren ausharren bund und
länder stellten neben mit einer
soforthilfe auch einen wiederaufbau von
in zweistelliger milliarden höhe zur
verfügung
etwas mehr als die hälfte der flut
schäden entfallen auf rheinland pfalz
mehr als 40 prozent auf nordrhein
westfalen und der rest auf bayern und
sachsen alles in allem war 2021 das
teuerste jahr für versicherer seit fast
50 jahren für überschwemmungen und
starkregen wurden neun milliarden euro
veranschlagt für sturm- und hagelschäden
zwei milliarden die naturgefahren
schäden an kraftfahrzeugen lagen bei 1,5
milliarden euro
künftig sieht die
versicherungswirtschaft besondere
risiken auf sie zukommen schäden infolge
der klimakrise werden wohl zunehmen der
dax hat sich ganz gut geschlagen am
heutigen tag am ende des tages ein plus
von 0 5 prozent bei einem stand von
15.800 35 punkten lieferengpässe und
omikron scheinen zurzeit etwas ihren
schrecken verloren zu haben an den
börsen blickt man durchaus optimistisch
ins kommende jahr vielen dank sina für
heute
eine schwere hochwasser katastrophe
trifft in diesen tagen auch brasilien
lange und heftige regenfälle haben dort
60 orte unter wasser gesetzt im
östlichen bundesstaat bahia erbrachen
zudem zwei staudämme die region leidet
seit wochen unter unwetter und
überschwemmungen nach brasilianischen
medienberichten kamen dabei bislang 18
menschen ums leben fast
20.000 verloren ihre häuser
in österreich ist rund 100 britischen
touristen wegen fehlender im pfund test
nachweise die einreise nach tirol
verwehrt worden seit samstag müssen
reisende aus von omikron besonders
betroffenen ländern eine
auffrischungsimpfung und einen aktuellen
pcr test nachweisen die österreichische
tourismus und gastronomie branche blickt
mit sorge auf die drohende mikrowelle
und neue einschränkungen so gilt seit
heute auch eine frühere sperrstunde in
restaurants ab 22 uhr
so prächtig waren die eröffnungsfeiern
in galway irland und rijeka kroatien als
die kulturhauptstädte des jahres 2020
wurden eine ehre die erst mal viel geld
kostet und dann hoffentlich besucher
anlockt die geld da lassen für 2021 wäre
diese rechnung nicht aufgegangen wegen
pandemie also wurden für dieses jahr
keine kulturhauptstädte benannt für 2022
dann gleich drei eine davon liegt in
luxemburg es so als ob die stadt hebt
gleich eine ganze region bis nach
frankreich rein ins zentrum der
aufmerksamkeit wie macht man das in
einem kleinen staat der seinen aktuellen
reichtum als steueroase verdient hat und
seinen alten reichtum als stahl und
kohle region susanne freitag zeigte al
sadd bringt das fertig mit einer kultur
des wandels
[Musik]
das war mal eine stahlfabrik
vor sechs jahren hat arcelormittal in
esch schiff los alles dicht gemacht
jetzt soll die industrieruine eine
kulturfabrik werden für tanz und
installationen
es hat sein kunstwerk schon begonnen
lange bevor das offizielle programm der
europäischen kulturhauptstadt fest stand
jetzt ist er plötzlich teil davon
meine ganze familie hat ihr gearbeitet
arbeiterfamilie heben und
deshalb so allein bedeutet mir sehr viel
und auch dieses mobile hier das gefällt
mir sehr gut weil aus vergänglich ist
bei es 20 22 wird die ganze region mit
einbezogen
weil die eisen und stahlindustrie
grenzübergreifend war ist es auch das
kulturprojekt 19 gemeinden gehören dazu
11 in luxemburg 8 in frankreich wir
wollen wirklich dass sie dann mit macht
jeder gemeinde auch wenn es eine ganz
kleine gemeinde ist wir sind der meinung
dass die alle ganz wichtig sind dass die
eine ganz spannende geschichte haben
auch in punkto erbe und das könnte hier
natürlich zusammen auch aufbauen und
zeigen
es ball ist die vorzeigegemeinde des
strukturwandels die alten hochöfen
wurden in ein modernes stadtviertel
integriert startups hightech die uni
ein paar kilometer weiter in moderne
tisch in frankreich hat der
strukturwandel weniger gut funktioniert
der jobsuche geht rüber nach luxemburg
das kulturprojekt macht hoffnung
dass der schon gut für unsere jugend ist
wenn ihr ein bisschen kultur hin käme
dass die arbeit oder eine beschäftigung
haben hier ist ja sonst nichts
am ort fand die gruppe
1997 hat sie dicht
nicola got to go macht sie jetzt mit
freunden wieder auf ihre großväter haben
hier eisenerz gefördert sie fördern
jetzt gut
sie machen die maschinen wieder fit
wollen ein restaurant eröffnen und einen
ist
nicolas großvater kam aussieht
in den donnerstag und die wurde diese
gruppe ist ein symbol unserer
einwanderungs kultur es waren die
einwanderer die uns zu dem gemacht haben
was wir heute sind diese vielfalt
verdanken wir dem bergbau und der
stahlindustrie
als kohle und stahl noch pumpen kamen
menschen aus vielen ländern zum arbeiten
hier her historischer kulturen nichts
dies sind wenn wir das ist super es ist
eine schöne stadt und man sagen da ist
sei die bunteste standort limburg
ab februar schlägt in der region an der
grenze das multikulturelle herz
tolle geschichte aus problemen gemacht
kultur der zukunft wir wünschen ihnen
noch einen schönen abend und sehen uns
hoffentlich morgen wieder ist an sein
amt
[Musik]
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter um die kaltluft aus dem osten
abzudrängen braucht es kräftige tiefs
die mit viel wind und wärme dagegen
drücken und genau danach sieht es aus in
mehreren schüben communitys vorwärts mit
wärme und drängen die kalte luft
allmählich nach osten hin ab in der
nacht gibt es glätte von der ostsee über
die mitte bis nach südosten in jedes
glatteis mit dabei ansonsten viele
wolken und regen die sich allmählich
weiter ostwärts durchsetzen ja und die
temperaturen dazu minus fünf grad im
osten deutschlands und 8 grad nach
südwesten hin morgen tagesverlauf ist
viel los in der mitte viel regen nach
osten kann es noch mal glatt werden und
auch richtung bayerischer wald richtung
berlin scheint auch mal die sonne
ansonsten ganz im westen deutschlands
gibt es gewitter dazu teilweise
stürmischen wenn wind aus südwestlichen
richtungen temperaturen dazu erreichen
höchstwerte von zwei grad an der ostsee
und 13 grad im südwesten deutschlands
aber das geht noch viel milder am
mittwoch temperaturen bis 14 grad im
südwesten die kälte wird allmählich
ostwärts ab gedrängte und dazu gibt es
viele regen ja noch milder wird es dann
am donnerstag bis 16 grad weiterer regen
silvester 9 bis 16 grad und dazu im
nordwesten regen und stürmischer wind im
süden sieht etwas freundlicher aus und
damit ein schöner abend